- [Mark] All right, Lucky.
- [Lucky] Mhm.
- [Mark] Lucky, where'd you grow up,
where are you from, originally?
- [Lucky] I'm really from
Pasadena, California.
I was raised in placements in foster homes
and juvenile halls most the time there.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You had both parents?
Sounds like you didn't.
- [Lucky] No, my mom left when I was five,
and my dad, we didn't get too long.
We stopped talking when
I was about 11 or 12.
- [Mark] And then, so
how was your childhood?
- Oh, very, very messed
up, very messed up.
I was molested by my uncle for
two years when I was a kid.
My dad used to...
He'd be real aggressive with me.
He didn't like the fact that I hung out,
chose to hung around black people.
He used to beat me, call me
nigger lover, nigger traitor.
I mean race traitor, nigger lover.
I remember a couple of nights,
he made me sleep in the
backyard with my dog
in the broke down car and watched me
from his bedroom window.
Such and such.
- [Mark] And you went
on your own at what age?
- I would say I was,
I was completely on my own around 14, 15.
- [Mark] Yeah, and you joined a gang?
- Yeah, I joined a gang early, about 13,
but I was completely on
my own, separated from...
I was on the streets 14-15.
- [Mark] So you joined which gang?
- Pasadena Denver Lane Blood.
- [Mark] So you're a Blood.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] You're a white,
you're a Caucasian-
- Very much so.
- [Mark] And you're in
a totally black gang.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] How is that?
- Being that I was growing
up in the nineties,
when it was really...
The gang banging that you see nowadays
is not the gang banging
that gang banging is.
It's, now you're getting
what you would say,
the placebo of gang banging.
Nineties it was more hands-on.
So, it was a little rough for me,
being white for a black gang.
Had to prove myself to the blacks,
had to differ myself
from whites and Mexicans.
So, it was rough enough.
- [Mark] And you've done prison time?
- Yes, sir, 13 years.
- [Mark] What was that for?
- Home invasion.
Home invasion and being a gang member.
- [Mark] So what do you
credit about your childhood
that maybe led you into this lifestyle?
- I wouldn't say, I don't
blame me joining the lifestyle.
See my way of thinking
is a little different.
I don't blame me joining the lifestyle on
my mom and dad not being there.
That's, I wasn't looking
for connections or...
It was...that's what interested me.
That's what attracted me, that's...
Gang banging.
Not just gang banging,
but the reality of life.
The waking up every day, going to school,
soccer practice after
school, pizza after the game,
back home, bed, watch ABC family.
That's a small percentage of
America, very small percentage.
Everybody else is
abused, homeless,
hurting, hiding something, afraid,
and that's the reality of the situation.
And it's not about going
out to pull no guns
because gang bangers, they
don't just walk around
looking to shoot somebody or what not.
It's somebody has come to they community
or their area of the town,
and chose to try to bring
harm or disrespect it
and such is (indistinct).
But that's what it used to be, so.
I think, I don't know.
I credit, I don't know.
Maybe my attitude just
attributed to me gang banging.
I don't know, but I was,
you could say I was angry.
I was angry at my dad, hurt about my ma,
take a long time for me to
get over my mom leaving.
Broke a lot of trust with females.
- [Mark] Do you have relationships?
You been married or-
- No-
[Mark] Do you have kids?
- No I have no kids.
I'm 37.
I spent from 21 to 33 in prison.
I was stabbed 10 times
in prison, but I don't...
Relationship wise is...
I've been in two relationships
and both relationships
have been with those
females, they cheated on me.
Even though...
My mom leaving me should of had me
walk on caution when it comes to relation-
The females that are believable.
People say, I still wear
my heart on my sleeve.
Cause I'm not a behind the
scenes type of individual.
I straight forward, so, I
wear my heart on my sleeve,
and I give my heart to the
wrong people that don't need it.
So it ends up...
It's just as in life, I give
my heart to the wrong people
and got fucked over.
I might be off the question a little bit.
That is just...
- [Mark] Do you have friends?
- Very seldom will I
call a person a friend.
They have to be real.
I got shot last year,
and I was behind someone who
was acting like a friend.
I got shot at twice last year.
Then, I got shot at twice,
I got my leg shattered.
I got 14 screws in there.
Then I was in a wheelchair for two months.
Then I went to jail for eight months on
bull shit by the police, or
six months bull shit by police.
I get out of jail, and my
girl at the time tells me
that she fucked my homie
while I was in jail.
So this last year has been a fucking...
(blows through lips)
- [Mark] Is it hard being,
being in prison and being white,
even though you were in a
black gang, how was that?
- That's not, that's 13 years of war.
Every tattoo I have on my body
is from the penitentiary.
White boys didn't like it too much,
but my theory was,
I wasn't that way on the street,
so why am I gonna be that way in prison?
The whole factor of me
being from my neighborhood
is being from my neighborhood.
What do I look like going to prison
and letting this white boy tell me
if I don't get with
what he's talking about,
then I'm gonna get hurt?
So I chose to go with my homies,
and I got stabbed in my stomach,
my armpits, sliced in my
arm, sliced in my neck.
Just over the course
of years (indistinct).
14 stitches on my face,
same stitches on that side.
- [Mark] Yeah, what, are
you using any of the drugs
that are on the street?
- Do I use any drugs on the street?
I do
become a victim sometimes
of things I use to maintain.
I smoke a lot of weed.
I'm weed head, I'll profess
that all day, every day.
Sometimes I do meth.
It calms me down and focuses me,
not like other people, I don't know
I like to read when I get...
- [Mark] And the gang life for you is,
it's changed since you started, right?
- Oh yeah, and that's one of the reasons
I stick to myself
because now it's just...
(blows through lips)
- [Mark] Do you still consider
yourself a gang member?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, but you're just not doing
the same things you were doing?
- No I'm, that's not, I'm a gang member.
I'm just not out gang banging.
Gang banging is phases, phases.
- [Mark] And where do you
think you'll be in 5, 10 years?
(blows through lips)
- On everything I love a year ago, I would
have been saying still somehow...
God's gonna work out for me.
He's going to work my
life out no matter what,
but that's short of me saying,
God's going to put me
on a house in the hills.
He's gonna need, something's
just gonna (claps)
I've been through, I
lost too much in my life
to keep on losing, so, but...
Getting shot at, and,
twice this last, past year, and...
I'm just tired of police harassing me.
I'm tired of, I went to jail
at least nine times last year,
ten times, just in and out.
I'm tired of police harassment,
tired of getting shot at.
I'm tired of people telling me
they love me and don't love me.
I just, I thank God for every
day I'm living, that's all.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- In life?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Don't let this world
take your essence,
take who you are.
Whether they tell you it's right or wrong
or whatever it may be.
If you fight day to day, and
then struggle being who you are
don't let nobody ever tell
you you're wrong for that.
And don't let this world take that.
Whether it's a soccer player,
whether it's a gang banger,
whether it's a homosexual,
whatever it may be.
Don't let this world take your essence
because that's what
this world wants to do.
- [Mark] What personality
traits do you have
that kind of help you get by in the world?
- [Lucky] I'd say understanding.
I appreciate the people
out there on the street.
Because that's struggling,
that's worry, that's stress.
What you going to wear to your son's
soccer game on Saturday?
That ain't stress.
What?
You're arguing if you gonna save leftovers
or throw them in the trash?
That's not stressed, that's wastefulness.
That's stress out there.
Trying to fight something,
trying to understand yourself
and why you'd rather sell on the curb
and drink a bottle of alcohol
while your wife passes out
on the heat next to you
and just watch her, that's
stress, that's worry.
That's why I appreciate them.
Even though they don't
appreciate theyself.
Someone's got appreciate
it and I don't know.
I guess, I got a lot going
on in my head and shit.
So, it's, last year has been rough for me.
So, I choke up a lot lately.
You fight the fight,
and I understand that.
And that's the one thing
I stand by in my life.
- [Mark] What was the
hardest part of your life?
Being in prison?
- [Lucky] No.
I'm a fighter by nature, so that's not...
Not a fighter in the
sense I cause chaos, but,
I'm a stand-up guy by nature,
so I'm not gonna...
Getting over the mental
struggle, and, shit I had to go through
after my uncle molested me.
That's probably it.
And,
not having, not never been able to
know or
experience a
genuine, honest type of love.
Not just relationship-wise,
but for anybody.
- [Mark] Your parents?
- Parents, anybody.
Everybody that's come to
my life said they loved me-
(claps)
Bullshit.
- [Mark] Do you feel like
you've ever been loved?
- No.
Never.
- [Mark] What regrets do you have,
looking back at your life?
- I don't regret,
I don't regret nothing about my life.
Cause I love who I am,
so I can't regret nothing else.
I'd regret myself, but,
the thing I don't,
I don't know.
- [Mark] You don't have
any regrets it sounds like.
- No, I don't have no regrets.
- [Mark] That's okay.
- Yeah, I don't have no regrets.
- [Mark] Nothing wrong with that.
- No, I don't have no regrets.
I appreciate everything
God's given me, good and bad.
- [Mark] Are you religious?
- I'm not religious.
I believe in God.
I got the light on inside of
me, I'm not religious though.
That's made up, that's false.
- [Mark] What do you think
the gang life helped you with?
What kind of things did you learn there?
- If you take it to my way and
take it with a grain of salt,
and you experience what
you need to experience
and learn from it, you
become a better man.
You become
an understanding man, a patient man.
- [Mark] Alright, Lucky.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
- No, thank you for letting me.
I apologize if any questions
that I didn't answer right.
- [Mark] No, you did great.
Excellent, and good luck with everything.
- Thank you, I appreciate it.
- [Mark] Thanks man.